this is cereth registered nurse RN calm
and in this video i'm going to be going
over Rh incompatibility in this video is
part of an ink lex review series over
maternity nursing so let's get started
first let's start out talking about what
is RH and compatibility well this is
where you have a mother who is Rh
negative and she's carrying a baby that
is Rh positive and what happens is
usually at the end of the pregnancy
whenever it's time to deliver the baby
the blood from the baby will mix into
mother's circulation and this will cause
mom's body to create these antibodies
because whenever this Rh positive blood
got into Mama's system who's Rh negative
the body sees that I was like a foreign
invader and it's like oh we've got to
create these antibodies so next time we
see this we can't attack and that's just
what it does during the second pregnancy
whenever mom gets pregnant again and she
carries an Rh positive baby so what
happens these antibodies get in there
and they attack the baby causing severe
anemia heart failure and jaundice which
we're gonna be going depth about the
path oh and what's happening to the
child and the prevention and the nursing
care here in a moment but first let's
talk about red blood cells okay in our
blood typing video we learned about the
various blood types you can have a you
can have B you've got a B or oh and
based on whatever type you are let's say
your type a you have a antigens on your
red blood cell surface you're type B you
have B antigens on that surface and then
so forth we also learned that on the red
blood cell a person can either have it
or they don't a special protein called
Rh factor so if a person has these
little special protein factors on here
what are they known as they're known as
Rh positive okay but if they don't have
these factors they're absent on that red
blood cell surface they're known as Rh
negative and that's what we're talking
about here
our mother doesn't have these proteins
present on her red blood cell surface
and here's the thing if you're Rh
positive you can easily receive positive
or negative factor blood without any
problems no antibodies being created
however if you're Rh negative you can
only receive other Rh negative blood you
can't receive positive because if you
did you'll create these antibodies that
will actually attack those red blood
cells and that is really what's going on
here in this whole condition so now
let's talk about how this happened okay
we have a father he is Rh positive so he
has these proteins present on his red
blood cell surface then we have a mother
who is Rh negative
she doesn't have these proteins now it's
a really high probability that they're
gonna have a baby that is Rh positive
but let's say that they didn't it was an
Rh negative baby everything's fine cuz
remember momma can receive other Rh
negative blood into her system but she
can't receive positive Rh factor blood
in her system or let's say that the
father was Rh negative mom is Rh
negative that's fine or if father was Rh
negative and Mama was Rh positive that's
fine because like I said the beginning
the lecture mom can receive positive and
negative blood so baby was negative it
would be okay now typically in the first
pregnancy the baby is not affected
because this happens these antibodies
are created once that baby is delivered
when that placenta comes off of the wall
the blood from the baby will go into
Mama's circulation the body will see
that Rh positive blood and say we're not
gonna have any of that that's a foreign
invader and creates these antibodies so
baby's gone by the time these antibodies
are really formed and ready to attack if
they see Rh positive blood again however
sometimes this can happen early on where
baby's blood enters into mom's
circulation like with a trauma like
abruptio placentae where some of that
placenta has came off the uterine wall
either partially or totally baby's blood
goes into mom so
halation antibodies are created baby's
still in there and those antibodies can
attack or like with an invasive
procedure like an amniocentesis or
whatever the patient can have where the
Bloods going to pass over now the thing
is is whatever that happens once that Rh
positive blood gets into this Mama's
blood that's Rh negative the mama has
become sensitized to it and as
healthcare professionals we want to
prevent that which is why it's important
we give rhogam and we test them on this
blood type early on and those prenatal
visits to see what she is which we're
going to really jump into here in a
moment so now let's look at this second
pregnancy okay mom is now sensitized she
became sensitized over here in that
first pregnancy she has all these
antibodies in her system that are on the
lookout for red blood cells with
positive Rh factor because they seen
them before
and next time they see it they're going
to attack so we have again or Rh
positive father Rh negative mother real
high probability they're gonna have
another Rh positive child but by chance
if they have an Rh negative child this
isn't going to happen it's just with the
baby who's Rh positive so here we have
these antibodies and a neat thing that
occurs during pregnancy naturally is
called passive immunity it's where mama
is passing some of her antibodies that
she's built up over the years to help
that child survive once it's born from
oven bacterium viruses that are
naturally in our environment but also
what's getting passed to this child are
these antibodies that she created over
here and these antibodies again their
goal is to attack red blood cells with
Rh factor that's on them so it senses
that it sees these red blood cells it's
like foreign invader attacks so it's
going to attack the baby's red blood
cells whatever whenever that happens
these red blood cells are going to
hemolysis which is going to draw the
count of red blood cells in the baby's
body now whenever that happens what do
red blood cells do they help transport
oxygen throughout the body which this
child really means that but that's not
going to really occur because we're
losing the
four of them because those antibodies
are attacking those red blood cells this
is going to cause severe anemia in this
child
now when anemia happens what organ is
really going to be affected that heart
because the heart pumps blood throughout
the body to give that oxygenated blood
it just received from the lungs to the
organs to the tissues and it's going to
sense that those oxygen levels have
dropped because there's no red blood
cells to carry that oxygen and so it's
going to try to step up its game it's
going to pump harder it's gonna pump
faster trying to get it there but it can
only do this for so long and it starts
to wear out whenever that happens the
baby will enter into heart failure and
when the heart muscles weak can't pump
fluid start building up and we get a
really big problem so that's why you're
gonna see a Deema swelling throughout in
addition from where those red blood
cells are breaking open from where you
have the breakdown of red blood cells
that's going to leak Billy Reuben into
the blood and we don't want it there and
the liver can't even conjugate it fast
enough because the liver and the spleen
are busy trying to make more red blood
cells and that's going to overwork those
organs you're going to get a splinter
megali increase in the size of the
spleen and heap at a mega ly increasing
the size of the liver and these red
blood cells that they're going to
produce really don't do much of anything
they're going to be immature and they're
too small to really help this child out
so the baby is going to experience
jaundice because of all that bilirubin
that's going to be in the blood and
bilirubin is really a neurotoxic agent
and it's not meant like I said to be in
the blood and it can really affect the
brain development of the baby so the
baby can have neuro issues as well if
they have too much bilirubin in their
system so as the nurse really the whole
key and preventing this from happening
is preventing this mom from becoming
sensitized we want to prevent that so
what do we do well during that prenatal
period we're going to look at there
type and look at their Rh factor and if
they're a negative B negative a B
negative or a negative throwing to
receive a rhogam shot and it's given I
am intramuscularly and the woman will
receive it at 28 weeks and after
delivery if her baby is indeed Rh
positive they will test that and she'll
need to get that other shot within 72
hours after delivery and how does rhogam
work what does it do well what it does
is it softs immune system from creating
those antibodies so when that blood from
that Rh positive baby enters into the
circulation this rhogam which is already
on board will prevent that immune system
from creating those antibodies so mom's
not going to become sensitized now
rhogam is not effective if moms already
been sensitized she already has those
antibodies present so it won't really
work now it's really important that
rhodium is given with each pregnancy to
prevent mom from becoming sensitized
okay so that wraps up this lecture on Rh
incompatibility thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos